good morning Hank it's Tuesday March 11
three days before I have to turn in the
first draft of the Paper Towns
screenplay so Hank I was going to try to
break the question Tuesday world record
today but I just don't think I have time
I've got to get back to writing the
screenplay but the fact that I have no
time at all today will not stop me from
answering at least some real questions
from real nerdfighters question 1
wearing when is your event in Amsterdam
next week it's on Thursday March 19th at
7 p.m. at D Yaron oh man how am I ever
going to immigrate to the Netherlands
when I suck so bad at Dutch anyway info
in the sidebar everyone in and around
Amsterdam should come also a quick
reminder this Friday I'm doing a
fundraiser for an awesome charity called
the second story in Indianapolis it's 5
bucks if you're a student eight bucks if
you aren't more info in the sidebar
whose 1977 asks how do I get nerve to
like me I don't know that's not really
my area of expertise hold on let me get
Willy hey Willy girls love you Willy how
do you do it kisses you lick their ears
I don't think that's I don't at least
not at first I don't think that's the
way to get it done man why do girls like
you is it because you pee a lot or
because you bark in the house or because
you make a lot of weird noises wait is
it because you're the silent shy aloof
type ah the silent child Luke type
doesn't lick me in the mouth when I'm
video blogging no I think I can tell you
pretty succinctly why girls like Willy
it's because he's a puppy guys my first
piece of advice about getting girls to
like you become a puppy a kitten would
also be acceptable or possibly a sneezy
panda bear goosh 1977 I've been dumped
by a lot of girls and in the process of
acquiring those broken hearts I learned
one important lesson girls don't like it
when you get all creepy stalkery on them
see the problem with guys is that were
needy but we're taught that we're not
allowed to be needy so when we get in a
situation where we're allowed to be
vulnerable we sort of like rip it open
and let the need flow out and it's kind
of disgusting I have this theory that
girls at least girls not named Bella
have this warning system inside their
heads and whenever we get too obsessed
with them and focused on them it's like
beep beep beep beep back away back away
beep beep beep beep back away which by
the way is a totally helpful warning
system because no girl or any other
person for that matter
we'll ever fill up the holes inside of
you it's like Chinese finger cuffs do
you remember Chinese finger cuffs the
way to get Chinese finger cuffs off of
your fingers is instead of being
panicked and overeager just relax
oh and one other thing guys it will be
really helpful if you can see girls as
like people instead of pathways to
kissing and/or salvation one of the
things I've noticed over the years is
that if you treat girls like people
although admittedly people who like fart
jokes somewhat less than the rest of
your friends they are much more likely
to like you question 3
hanka song wednesday but why don't you
ever sing if you watched all of our
videos you'll know that at the end of
2007 I gave the nerdfighters a gift and
that gift was me not singing anymore
question for any new hot youtubers oh
there are so many but recent new
favorites include Rance Riggs and wheezy
waiter they can be checked out in the
sidebar nerdfighters I'm up to 100 peeps
so far but that's nothing please keep
donating Hank I'll see you tomorrow for
Song Wednesday and the next time you see
me I'll be happy dancing in holland
dftba